- How is your mini golf game?
- It normal, on a normal course
is pretty good.
On this course
I'd be, I'd be soaking wet within seconds.
(laughing)
I love that you're like I would fail.
- Yeah.
- All right, well, do you,
I'm just wondering,
do you have like a putter, a cup,
you know, a golf ball handy,
anything like that?
Would you be maybe willing to bet me $20
you can sink a 10 foot putt?
I'm just saying.
- Challenge accepted, yes.
- Oh challenge accepted, okay.
I can't wait to watch you miss.
(laughing)
- All right, hold on.
I gotta see if I can get this going here.
All right.
- Oh my gosh, I can't play golf at all.
- Can you see the cup?
- Yes.
- Okay, I'm gonna give a shot here.
- Okay.
Oh my gosh!
I could end in it popped
and rejected your ball.
(laughing)
- Like bad, bad.
- It still, does it count?
- It does, I'm just kidding, it counts.
That's amazing!
I can't, I can't putt,
I was told, my friend and I,
anytime I like next time
we go golfing, I'm like,
I'm really good at
like, I'm Happy Gilmore.
I can nail, I could launch a ball,
but I just can't putt for anything.
You're amazing.
You're awesome.
- You gotta do team golf then.
- I know.
- You gotta do team golf.
Get someone who can putt.
- That's what I'm gonna do.